- Thank you so much for
joining today or this evening,
depending on where you're calling from.
This is Jeremy Shi at Khan Academy
and I'm so excited you're joining with us
because if anything, at Khan Academy,
2020 has been the year of the tablet.
We've given away by my
calculation, at least 50 tablets
over the course of the year
in response to questions like,
how does Sal Khan make those videos?
How can I make my own videos?
And that's why I'm so excited
about tonight's session
because now you're going to learn
from the experts themselves.
First of all, we are so
lucky to have Stacey with us.
Stacey is a math teacher
and director of innovation
educational technology at the
Bullet School in Maryland.
And one of the things
that really impresses me
is not only does she wear
multiple hats at school
but she's also the
author of Tech with Heart
which is an amazing book
on how to use tech in your classroom
not just to break your
students down to bits and bytes
but to actually empower
them, to lift them up.
And I think in 2020, I can't
imagine a better lesson
than how to use technology
in a more holistic way.
So check out Tech with Heart,
would make a great stocking stuffer.
And then also I have to
give a huge shout out
to the Wacom team.
If you're familiar with Wacom, the brand,
they're the world's leader
in handwriting tablets.
So whether you use it for
design or for teaching,
there's just these really powerful tools
to bring your teaching
style and your pedagogy
into the digital world.
And in fact, Sal Khan himself
has been using their tablets
for a decade at this point
and is still using them to make
videos at this very moment.
So a huge shout out to the Wacom team
and especially because Wacom
has been generous enough
to give away five more tablets,
to lucky attendees tonight
and you will be notified automatically
just for being in attendance.
If you're one of those lucky five.
And then in addition, even
if you're not selected
to win a tablet
walk is giving an exclusive discount code
just to attendees of the session
that Stacey will unveil at the
very end of the presentation.
Now, all that being said,
I would be remiss in 2020 on a webinar
not to mention that number
one, this is being recorded.
So you'll get all those
goodies in your email
right afterwards, including
a PDF of the handouts
and all the links that we talked about.
And then of course, because
we're educators, all in all
we want to make sure that the
session is really interactive.
So ask questions at any
point using the questions tab
and Stacey will take a ton
of those questions at
the end of the session.
So without further ado, let
me turn it over to Stacey
to tell you all about
how you can use tablets
in your own classroom to make
2021 even more effective.
Over to you, Stacey.
- Thank you so much.
I'm so excited to be
with you all this evening
or whatever time it is over on your end.
So I'm going to be sharing some ways
that you can use the tablet.
I have been using a Wacom
tablet myself for years now.
I think I got my first one in 2013.
And what I love about
these tablets is that
it's the same tablet
that I was using in 2013.
I'm still able to use today,
though I'm going to showcase
some of their newer products.
It has worked for me over the years
and it's a way of allowing
me to handwrite on anything.
And as a math teacher, I need that.
So in addition to my role
in really working as a coach
with teachers at my school
and helping them onboard
the tech that will work best
for their classroom, I'm
also an AP calculus teacher.
So I've taught a number
of classes over the year
but in the past several years,
I've taught AP calculus AB.
I also taught a purely online
version of AP calculus AB
for a number of years
and I am a flip classroom teacher.
So I'll get into a lot
of how I started exploring the tablets
and how I'm using them now.
And hopefully some easy ways
to help you get started.
If you are on Twitter, I would
love to connect with you.
My Twitter hashtag is, or my
Twitter handle is @buddyXO.
So if you are there,
please connect with me.
And if you have any questions at all,
I'm so happy to follow up
and answer as many as I can.
I do have a contact form on my blog.
So now that we're done
with that little intro,
let's go ahead and let me start
off with some of the things
I hope to achieve today.
First of all,
how to get started with
a whiteboard application.
Then how to use a scratch
pad in Khan Academy?
Then we'll talk more
about how to ink up slides
and make screencasts of your own.
And then as Jeremy said, we
will have some time for Q&A.
So before we get started,
I'm gonna just put a question out to you.
What subject do you teach
and what grade levels do you teach?
Go ahead and type that in.
- [Jeremy] Okay. We've got
the poll on your screen.
So feel free to start
answering right there.
About a third of the 500 or so educators
across the country have answered.
We're up to about two thirds now.
And it looks like there
are a lot of educators
who are following in
your footsteps, Stacey,
because as we close the
poll and share the results,
you can see that a plurality
are math educators.
- Awesome.
- [Jeremy] And now we'll
do the same, that's right,
but also a nice diversity of educators
across the content spectrum.
Let's do the same for grade level now.
So elementary, all the way to high,
maybe even beyond or before.
It's looking like a
little bit of a horse race
between middle and high school.
And we'll go ahead and share that.
And it looks like a lot
of high school educators.
Again, your tribe is here
in force tonight, Stacey.
So a lot of high school math
educators have joined us.
- All right.
Well, we'll have some fun tonight.
So this is me back in the day.
Let me go back into present.
This is me back in the day
when I started flipping my classroom.
This was back in 2010.
And what I had here was
a tablet PC, actually.
So this is how I got
started making my videos.
I had a microphone that I got
and I was using my tablet PC,
which is what we have through our school.
That was kind of how I got
interested in the first place.
I said, Hey, I got this
technology in my hands.
Let me start making some
screencasts for my students.
Especially when I started
AP calculus teaching,
you know how much content
there is to get through,
not enough time to get through it.
So wanted a way to offload
that very teacher
directed lecture to video,
and I started using my
tablet PC to do that.
However, I am a Mac user
and this tablet PC wasn't my preference.
So when I learned about Wacom,
then I had my solution because
I could plug the tablet
into my Mac and I still had
the pen and the handwriting.
And I've been happily using
that solution ever since.
So there are two main
types of Wacom devices.
There is the slate style
like this one in the left.
So this is a blank slate.
And you can write just
looking up at the screen
is what you would have to do there
so that you're not seeing
what you're writing.
Actually, you're looking up at the screen
to see what you're writing.
And then there's also the
display style tablets,
like this one where you actually
either mirror your screen
or you use it as a second display,
just like if you had
another monitor attached.
So that is really amazing,
especially remote learning.
I think we've all learned
that we need two monitors.
And so this can be a simple
way to have two monitors
available to you or two
screens available to you.
So I really recommend the Wacom Intuos.
There are different styles
of it, but I like the one.
This is the small one that I have.
It's a small style, but it is Bluetooth.
And I love that because it's wireless
and I can move it around,
easy to carry with me
when we are in the actual classroom
and we're able to move around.
This is a great device to
have, throw it in your bag.
And then the Wacom One
is what I actually make
flip classroom videos with nowadays.
You do have to plug it in.
So it is much larger.
I have it right here.
I don't have it plugged in
'cause I didn't want another
screen going right now
but this is really great
because I can have it
to write out all of my lessons,
make my screen recordings,
and it feels so natural.
It really feels like writing on paper.
The quality of this tablet is amazing,
and I recommend the Wacom One
because it's the lowest price point
for a screen display style
tablet that Wacom offers.
And it's met all of my
needs as a math teacher
a hundred percent, and it
feels so, so nice to write on.
So those are the two style of tablets.
Just wanted to throw those
out there for some background.
And then I'm gonna pose one
more question to you right now.
Do you currently have a writing tablet?
So I think there's a poll that
you can answer on this one
- [Jeremy] And it looks like
we're up to about almost 90%
of the votes here, Stacey.
It looks like about, as you
can see here on the screen,
about a third of teachers had
that writing tablet already
but the majority do not.
So just a little good background to go on.
- Awesome, so hopefully
that some of that background
was helpful in helping you
understand the different styles
of tablets that are available
and which one you might want
to purchase going forward.
If you really just are
looking to just get started
with the most affordable option
and the most portable option,
that is the Intuos style tablet.
And again, there's a
Bluetooth version of that,
which is what I really like
because I can just be using it,
just click a button, no wires needed,
and I can move around and it's wireless.
Again. The Wacom one.
I love it for making my
flip classroom videos.
It does need to be plugged in.
So I just like to mention that
because I think it's important
to weigh the options.
Do you need portability
or are you going to be
making videos all the time?
In which case, I think the Wacom One
is really worth the investment.
That's what I use most of
my time and I just love it.
All right, so let's continue on
and start with some of the basics.
So I wish that I could just tell you, Hey,
this is what I recommend.
This is what you should do.
But the reality is we are
all at different schools
that use different technologies,
that have different subscriptions
but also we're at Google Schools.
We are at Microsoft schools.
We are at Google Meet schools.
We are at Zoom schools right now.
And so I am going to present,
again, a variety of options,
ones that I would most
recommend depending on
which of those camps you fall into.
So if you are using
Google everything already,
if you're using Google Meet,
even if you're using Zoom and
your school is a Google school
I think Google Jamboard is the
simplest whiteboarding option
that I can possibly offer you.
There is a video of how
the Google Meet integration
with the Jamboard whiteboard works
if you haven't used that before and again,
these resources are available after
and I put a little play
button so that you can know
that you can watch this video afterwards
if you want to review it.
I'm trying to load you
up with some resources
to really help you out.
But I'm going to show
you just a basic demo
and you can get started by just
going to your Google Drive,
pressing the new button,
go into more and then
using a Google Jamboard.
And that's how you start
up a new whiteboard.
Or if you're in a Google
Meet, you'll see that option
right when you click the three dots.
So let me show you what
a Jamboard looks like.
It is super simple, super
basic, but it is collaborative,
or it can be just more instructional.
So like anything else in Google,
you can share this and make
everybody else an editor,
or you can share it with
view only permissions.
If everybody else has an editor,
it's real-time collaboration.
Amazing. Right?
So there is a pen tool right here.
And again, the options with
this one are very, very simple.
You only have a couple
pallets of color here.
You do have different pen thicknesses.
You have a marker, you have a highlighter,
you have more of a brush tool.
And so, you know, you can just
very simply get to writing.
If you want to write, you
can also pull in an image.
So sometimes I like to
use this to say, you know,
you have a question that you want,
take a snapshot of the
question, pull it into here
and then just use your tablet and write.
That's basically it.
And you can present during
class with this also.
There's this nice laser pointer.
So it's easier for students
to follow what you are writing
and you can more easily point.
There's a sticky note that you can have.
And then for my people
who need some shapes,
there's some basic shapes
here available too.
So this I think is one of the
simplest options available.
It is automatically built into Google Meet
if you're using that
or if you're using
Google Drive, I'm sorry.
If you're a Google school,
then this will save to your Google Drive.
So that's the nice ability there too.
And you can share, lastly,
you can always export this,
save this as a PDF afterwards,
so that you can share
these as lesson notes.
If you can't get everything on one slide,
you can make multiple
pages just like that.
And so those are the very very basics
of getting started with this.
And there's also the ability
to have some grid paper background also.
So, let me go ahead and
move into the next option,
which since I was on Google schools,
this one is really, I feel
like if you are a Google school
that is already a Kami user,
if you are using Kami or if your school
has a site license to Kami,
I really recommend checking that tool out.
If you've not heard about it before,
it's not the absolute thing
that you need right now.
I want you to pick which one
is going to fit your needs
the best, but what Kami is,
it's integrated again with Google Drive,
but it also can be kind of
just a white boarding tool
because there are these amazing pen tools
built right into Kami.
This is a Chrome extension,
by the way, you can get it
so you can open any of your
Google Drive files with Kami.
You can also just go to Kami
on the web and you can write.
So again, I can just write and talk.
There's so many more
features available into Kami.
I could do a whole webinar
on Kami, to be honest.
There is even the ability to
make your whole screen capture
right here in Kami, if
you have a paid version.
But what I like to show here
is just like this, for example,
was I was just showing how
students can kind of upload work
that they were stuck on
and then they can pull
it all into a document.
And then I can use the pen
tools like I used right here
to guide to say where they
went wrong for example.
We can discuss errors as a class.
So again, this is one of
the really nice white boarding tool.
You can add extra pages as you go.
When you want to add more pages.
Again, if you need lined
paper, you can have that.
If you need grid paper, you can have that.
If you want a music sheet,
you can even add that.
So if you are using Kami already
and you haven't thought about using it
as kind of a white boarding tool,
that's going to be my
recommendation to you.
And that's really, again,
if you're a Google school
'cause that's tied with Google.
So let's move on from Google schools.
And if you're using Zoom,
Zoom has a whiteboard built right in.
So I have a demo here again,
if you want to watch this after the fact,
you can just press play
and watch how to get
started with the tool,
but it is one of the
simplest options available.
And what's more in Zoom,
you can actually write
anywhere on your screen.
So it doesn't have to just be a whiteboard
that you're writing on.
You can ink up anything
using the annotation tools
that are in Zoom.
So if you haven't used that before,
and if you're using Zoom, then again,
you use your Wacom tablet.
Now you have an actual pen,
and you can be hand writing
instead of, you know,
just using your mouse,
which is very difficult.
So that Zoom again, if you're using that,
I would definitely check out this video
if you're not already.
Final white boarding tool
that I'm going to showcase is
if you want something
that's not tied to Google
and not tied to Zoom but is
very simple to get started with.
I like AWW app, which is for a
right here, a web whiteboard,
and I'm just using it for free.
So you do get advertisements.
That is the only downside to this,
but otherwise it can be
a collaborative board
so I can invite other people to it.
So it can be collaborative,
or I can just be doing my
screenshare and writing.
There are some more options in this one.
So this is actually a tool
that I use quite often
'cause it's simple
but also there's a little
bit more functionality,
so I can upload a picture or even a PDF.
I usually just would upload
like a picture of a question
that I want to solve as a class.
And then I can choose
from more of a variety
of color palettes right here.
Or you can choose from the color wheel
so you can get more colors
right there available to you.
There's an undo button very easily.
And then again, you can be
writing as you're talking,
you have the eraser tool,
and this one gives you a
variety of options here
where it's like you can
change the size of the eraser.
You can also like erase the
whole thing in one click
which makes it a little bit easier to use
than just erasing little
bit by little bit,
especially when you're
doing like a whole lesson.
I know it sounds minor,
but it can be very helpful.
Again, you have some shape tools
and then you have some text.
What I like about this app too,
is that as you're writing,
so, you know, you can be doing a problem.
Let me change color like over here.
And then you can do is you
can actually zoom in and out
and you can write on
different parts of the board.
So I can be zooming out. I can
move my, write over here too.
Then I can move my whole board over.
So I just have, this is
kind of like a huge canvas
that I can have and I can keep writing.
And if I want to see everything,
a snapshot of everything
at the end of class, I can zoom way out.
I can do full screen,
and I can move around a
little bit more easily
with this little mini map tool here.
So it's, again, one of
those that you can explore
a little bit more, but
I've really liked this one.
It's very, but also a
little bit more robust
in terms of being, you know,
kind of like that canvas feel,
which I like, if you know, I
want to solve a big problem,
I don't have enough
retail space on my screen.
I can play a little bit more
with some of these options.
So that is AWW app.
And again, there's a paid
version or a free version.
I'm just using the free one.
All right.
- [Jeremy] Stacey, as you're
going to the next section.
I just want to give a shout out.
You're getting so much love on the chat.
People are saying, Oh, I
love Kami. I love Jamboard.
I love AWW.
So everyone is sharing
their favorite tools
and there are even some additional
ones that are popping up.
So thank you for sparking
the conversation.
- Oh, fantastic. I know.
And that's the hardest thing,
I want to come on here and like make this
as simple as possible for
everybody and say, you know,
like this is the best
one, but the problem is
there isn't a best one.
And as you can probably see
that coming into the chat,
there's probably a lot of conversation
about what people love.
And so again, I encourage
you to kind of think about
what tools your school's already using
and maybe there's one that
already resonates with you,
but also like getting
students on it more easily.
If you're already a Google school,
Jamboard is going to
be super simple for you
and for your students.
If your students are already using Kami,
that's going to be super simple to them.
You know, at this point
I don't want to present too
many more tools in my classroom
because we already went through, you know,
kind of some of the
pain, the growing pains
of getting onboard.
And that's always the hardest
part. Now we're in a routine.
So, all right.
So let's go ahead and dig
into using the scratch pad
in Khan Academy in case
you're not using that already.
So I'm going to go ahead right
now, actually, let me go back
and just tell you what
I'm going to talk about.
So the first thing I'm going to talk about
is using it in the student view.
So this would be from the assign tab,
and this is something that
students also have access to.
So even if they don't
have a device, you know,
even if they just need to use their mouse,
they can at least ink up a little bit
as they're thinking through things,
which I know is very difficult,
but you as a teacher can also use it.
So let me show you what I mean.
So if I am in that
assigned tab right here,
and then I click on to
any of the assignments
that I have given.
So let me go ahead and
click into this exercise.
And then if I click on student
view, so say for example,
I just want to do like
an introductory lesson.
I found some really nice questions
that were in Khan Academy.
I don't want to assign
them for students yet
to do on their own.
I want to just have a class
conversation about it.
I can go ahead and pull
this up on the board.
And then if you click on here,
the little white boarding tool,
then you'll see that again.
I get kind of like my grid paper
which I know we love as math teachers.
And I can just mark it up.
So, you know, I can be
writing and talking.
I think there's real power
in being able to highlight
while I'm talking,
being able to write so students
can follow what I'm doing.
So I'm saying, you know,
the limit as X approaches negative two.
So now I'm telling everybody, you know,
pull your eye to negative two here.
And again, it's just
this quick little visual
of like what's going on so
I can pull that out for them
and then say, you know, well,
what do you see going on
from the left-hand side?
And I can just be drawing
and talking at the same time.
And then my students can
maybe unmute their mic,
chat it out, we can talk about it.
And then, you know, just what's happening
from the right hand side.
And so we can discuss it.
And I think that just makes
for a really nice little discussion
and then we can choose
the answer together.
So this is, again, this could
be used for class instruction
or maybe you assigned something
and students got something wrong.
You could pull this up or you
could have them pull it up
on their screen share
and ask them to kind of use these tools
to try and explain what they were thinking
so that you can work through
it and coach them together.
So that's a really nice little tool
in case you haven't used it before.
And then the other way
that I wanted to show it is
after students have responded.
So say that you already
gave an assignment.
Everybody did it for homework.
Now you want to discuss it in class.
You can use a teacher report.
And again, there is a
drawing tool that's available
more on a sidebar in this case.
So let me go ahead and go back.
And this time I'm going to go
ahead and go into my scores
And let me click on this.
So now if we're reviewing
all students here,
say that I want to discuss this one.
This one person got it wrong.
So I can go ahead and pull
up the draw tool right here.
And then I can just write on the side.
So again, super simple.
I can't draw on the drawing
itself in this case,
but here was an example that
I just laid out right here.
For example, you know, you might say,
what are the three things
that you are looking for here?
And I could just write that out
and then I'm able to write that out
because I have the pen
tool on my Wacom tablet.
If I was using my mouse,
I would not be able to write that out.
So again, that can be a really nice way
to just talk about things in class.
So those are my two favorite
ways of the whiteboard
right within Khan Academy to
bring things out during class
or to do kind of one-on-one
individualized coaching,
the students also.
So let me pause again and
see if there's any questions
coming in before we get into
some simple screencasting options.
- [Jeremy] Yeah. So there are
so many questions, Stacey.
What I would recommend is why
don't we finish up the content
and then save maybe like 10, 15 minutes
and really dig deep into these questions.
- Sounds good to me. All right.
So again, I'm presenting four options here
depending on what you
need for screencasting.
When it comes to screencasting,
there are a lot of options out there.
I'm going to set it, again.
If you're a Google school
already using Google Meet
and if you already have
the ability to record,
not everybody has the ability
to record in Google Meet,
but if you have the ability
you would see it under your three dots
and you'd be able to record.
Everybody who's using Google
for education right now
should be able to record in Google.
They've made that available for this year.
So if you're doing that for
class already, you know what?
You can join a Google
Meet, just you and yourself
and make a nice little screencast
because you will have
created a video, right?
So you could just join the
Google Meet all by yourself.
You can open up, pop open
a Jamboard, for example
and use the white boarding.
There you go.
Simple whiteboard screencasts
that you can then,
it will upload it to your Google Drive.
And then you can give it to
students to go ahead and review.
If you are using Zoom,
there's a record option,
right in Zoom.
So you could use the
white boarding tool again
right in Zoom.
And you can just record.
Let's keep it simple.
If you are wanting a Chrome extension,
there are a couple.
You may have used Screencastify or Loom.
They're both very similar.
I usually recommend Loom because
it is free for educators.
Screencastify has a
limit for what you can do
with the free version.
So that's why I say Loom.
If you sign up as an educator,
not everybody knows about that.
There's an educator form
that you can fill out
in which case you get free access to Loom.
So that does allow you to
do both like, you know,
the little video and your
screencast at the same time
or you can just do the screencast.
You get to choose what
you want to do there,
screen only, screen and cam,
and you can record again.
You can upload that to your Google Drive.
You have some different options there.
And then lastly I'm going
to present one paid option,
which is Camtasia.
And I present that because
that's actually what I use
to record my videos.
That's what I've been
using since 2010 actually.
I use that to record my videos
and I use that to edit my videos.
So that's what I like about that is that
it does have a pretty robust editor also.
I can add in like little
annotations at the end.
I can cut things if I made a mistake,
I can do some transitions,
all of that good stuff.
So if you want to invest
a little bit more time
and energy into creating
videos and editing them,
that's something that you enjoy.
I really enjoy editing my videos.
Then I would recommend looking
into a Camtasia license
and make sure that you look
for an educator discount
on that because you have some
educator discounts available
but that is a paid option
and it is available
for both a PC or a Mac.
So I'm going to keep this
as simple as possible.
Again, one of the easiest ways
to start inking up anything
is to use PowerPoint actually.
And there is a pen tool available
even in PowerPoint Online.
So I'm going to show you PowerPoint Online
because this is how I actually
got started with things.
I just opened up a PowerPoint.
Like I had my PowerPoint as
my base, my presentation.
I had a question and a
lot of blank, white space
as you can see here, that's
kind of what it looked like.
Whatever's in red is what I wrote
while I was making the screencast itself.
And so when you do this in PowerPoint,
it's going to save all
the annotations too.
So then you have a kind
of a final version.
And I usually save my original version.
And I usually, I print out the
blank version for my students
so that they can take notes
right on the PowerPoint
as they're watching the video.
And then you can just go ahead
and go to this drawing tab.
I'm in PowerPoint Online here.
And then you go to the drawing tab
and you can choose from a
bunch of different colors.
And it's nice that it
has your recent colors
that are saved right here.
You can change the
thickness of the pen tool
and then you can also use
this different pen tool.
They're a little bit
different and have the colors.
You have the eraser,
you have a highlighter,
and you can just get started
with making a screencast.
So again, you could open this up,
then use one of screencasting
tools we talked about.
So you could open up a
Google Meet with you yourself
and press record.
You can open up Zoom and record yourself.
You could also use Screencastify.
I use Camtasia.
When I use Camtasia, something
else I like about that
is I can just like choose
what portion of the screen
I want to record.
So I would just like select
this portion of the screen
with my mouse, you know?
So it would like record just this portion.
And then obviously I was
not using my tablet there.
So it was very messy, but I
would just record that portion
and you wouldn't be able to see
any of the background stuff.
And so a lot of the different tools
allow you to choose just
a piece of your screen
instead of recording the entire screen.
So that's something to keep in mind also.
Loom has that ability, I know.
So yeah, that's the
easiest way to honestly,
to get started here,
PowerPoint, you use it
and it's all free.
If you have PowerPoint,
like the desktop version,
this is coming to Mac.
I don't think it's
rolled out to everybody.
I know I'm in a program
where I get some early releases of things.
So it is available on, I am
using it on my Mac right now.
There is a record slideshow.
It's been available on a PC for years.
If you have PowerPoint
downloaded to your computer.
You can actually, it's a one-stop shop
where you can create a
video and record your screen
right using PowerPoint all in one.
Like you don't even need a second tool.
If that's something that interests you,
I have a reference article
and also a video tutorial.
That is a Windows specific one
but it's should be similar
for the Mac starting soon.
Anyway, I just wanted to
present that as an option
if you're using PowerPoint,
this is something that a lot
of people aren't aware of,
again, it's record slideshow,
it's right baked into PowerPoint
and you can export it as a MP4.
If you want students
to watch it as a video
or you can also give a share link.
And that share link is kind of like
if I shared these Google
slides with you right now
where students can press
like the next button
and the next button, but
it will play like a video.
It's really cool. I encourage
you to check it out.
If you are a PowerPoint fan,
if you're not, though
I've provided some other options
for you to explore today.
So I did want to show
you my actual process.
And this is a video of my actual process.
These days I use Notability on my Mac.
I pay for that.
It wasn't very expensive,
but I did purchase Notability
which is a, you might be familiar.
There is an iOS
application for Notability,
but there's also a Mac application.
And I just like it as like I
have it as my digital notebook.
So that's what I'm using these days.
But honestly, I start
off with a PowerPoint,
and you can replicate the
same thing in PowerPoint.
And I use Camtasia to
make my screen recordings.
Then I upload those for students to watch.
So again, if you want
to see my exact process,
that video is available.
All right.
Last, I think this is like
almost my last question for you.
How many Flipgrid fans
do I have here today?
- [Jeremy] Okay, so let's
queue this one up here.
So we launched the Flipgrid poll
and it's looking like
a lot of folks love it.
Maybe more have never used it before.
So this is great, great chance
to share something powerful.
- All right.
- [Jeremy] So go ahead
and share those results.
It looks like about
70% have not tried yet.
So feel free to share more Stacey.
- Okay. So I am obviously
in the love it camp.
So Flipgrid, there's two main things
that you can do in Flipgrid.
One is that you can record, sorry.
You can have students record responses.
So it comes in all like a
grid of student replies.
I'm not going to focus on that today,
even though that is amazing.
I use it in my math class
all the time for students
to explain their math
thinking and I don't use,
they don't use any special white boarding
or anything like that.
They just use a phone and they hover it
over their piece of paper
and they talk about their math solutions
and it's all posted on one big grid.
But what I'm going to talk about today
is more of like the teacher
created portion here,
since that is the focus
of our session today.
So when you're in
Flipgrid and this is free,
free available for everybody,
there is something
called the shorts camera.
And that is to record a short video.
You can record up to 10 minutes in here.
So when I record a short, that's gonna be,
that's going to do my
whole screen recording
and provide me with a whiteboard.
This is super simple. All right.
So what I'm going to do here is I'm going
to go to my effects.
I know I'm covering a lot rather quickly.
So here we go,
and you can choose a board
and I can choose a whiteboard.
What you can do here is you
can also split the screen.
So I could be like in
the side of the video,
or I can just be like, I
want only a whiteboard.
And again, I have some
different types of paper
that I can choose from.
And then all I have to do
is press the record button.
Now it's actually recording
everything that I do,
so I can go ahead and I
can open up a pen tool.
I can change the color of my
pen and I can get to drawing.
So it's very simple, very quick.
I would just have this one screen.
I can always pause if I needed
to, I could reset my screen
so I could delete everything.
You can even in here,
just to let you know,
there is a record screen feature in here.
If you ever want to use
that to record your screen.
If I didn't already give
you enough options, right.
But what happens is once
you make this recording,
everything that I do so I can go ahead
and I can open up a pen tool.
All right, so if you
made a little mistake,
there is a very simple
editor here where you can,
like double, sorry,
you can double click and you can,
you know how you can trim
like the beginning or end of the video.
You're able to do that
here. So I can do that.
I can confirm. And now, say,
you forgot to add a clip.
You can add more or you
want multiple boards.
You can do that.
Another way that I really
like to use this is to, again,
just upload a little image.
So maybe I have an image of a graph
and then I can just draw on that graph.
Let me show you how you do that. Add more.
I can go ahead into my effects
and I can use the photo
and you can go ahead
and upload a screenshot,
maybe from your textbook
or whatever it may be.
And then you would be able
to just ink on top of it,
how you can ink on top of it, again,
is you just go into these
drawing tools right here.
And that's really, that's really it.
I won't show you all the
fancy frames that you can do
which the kids love, you
know, all that good stuff.
And then when you're all
done, you go to the next,
next, you can title it if you want,
you choose a cover photo.
So let's just choose something
from the middle there.
There we go. Confirm, great image.
And the beauty of this is
it's going to generate a link
for me right now.
And that's the link that
I share with my students.
That's it. And now this is a video.
There's nothing else to
do. There's no uploading.
There's no downloading.
This is a quick whiteboard style video.
I guess it's preparing
it still. That's it.
See, it's available already. That's it.
And now it's actually.
So I'll just stick with that.
There's so much more in
Flipgrid that you can do,
but I'll stick with the simple again,
if I talked about that too quickly,
and this is an option that you're like,
Oh this is great, simple, let's
get started with that one.
I have a little video tutorial
on how to set up your Flipgrid,
how to get started with that also.
All right, so I want to leave
plenty of time for that Q&A,
like you said, the last piece,
which I'm not going to get in today,
but I just wanted to present is,
the last piece of like,
how do we engage our
students during class?
Because this is more like
instructional stuff that we do,
but what do you do during
class time to make sure
that all students are
really participating?
I am really lucky in that
I actually have a class set
of these Wacom tablets.
So you can see my students
writing with the Wacom tablet.
I pair this up with Pear Deck
and Pear Deck is a
add-on for Google Slides.
It's also available for,
for PowerPoint Online.
And it allows me to see the
work of all different students
in this dashboard view in real time.
And this is how I how I was using it now,
where students don't
actually have a tablet.
I'm just doing the writing with my tablet.
Students can still like circle an answer
so I can see if students are all trying.
If they're all responding, if
they're giving it some effort,
and then I can kind of, you
know, write out my reply.
And so the only reason
that I bring this up
is that we might have an opportunity
to bring you all another webinar.
So we just wanted to gauge some interest
to see if you would be
interested in learning more
about like that class discussion piece,
learning more specifically
about how I use Pear Deck.
We could probably,
we could definitely do
a whole webinar on that.
So we're going to do a
quick little survey right
after the session ends to
see if that is something
that you are interested in.
I'm going to just close with this quote.
I really believe if we empower
students with the resources
they need and coach
them through the process
of using these tools, then
students can take ownership
for their learning and that's
where the real magic happens.
And so for me, flipping my classroom,
giving my students all the
resources through the video
that I prepared them with before
they even walk into class,
oh my gosh, it's been so transformational.
I really didn't even get to
talk about my flip classroom,
kind of how that's
transformed my teaching.
I assign my videos through a tool
where I can see how students
are watching the videos.
I can embed questions in the videos.
I come to class prepared because
I know what students need
and that has been really
transformational for me.
But of course the first step
is knowing how to make the videos.
So hopefully you got some ideas today
and we'll have plenty of time for Q&A.
Of course, I want to share
that code for you all
to get a discount on a Wacom product.
Thank you again, to Wacom
for offering this discount
for everybody joining today.
So there are a lot of
different products to explore.
So this link will be
dropped into the chat.
I see Jeremy's already
done that. Thank you.
And you can explore the different
devices that are available
and you would save 10% with the
code that's available there.
All right, should we dig into the Q&A?
- Let's do it.
And I'm going to give you
a huge shout out, Stacey
because I know you can't see it
but there is so much love
pouring into the question section
saying, best professional
development ever.
I've learned more in 40 minutes
than I learned in life 40
hours of traditional training.
So thank you for being
really, really actionable
with the kinds of tools that
teachers can use tomorrow
wherever their students are.
But let's back up one little bit here
because at the very
beginning of this session,
Michael wants to know,
what do these tablets even look like?
Like, what does it look
like when a teacher uses it?
If you don't mind holding up yours,
just give a sense of how
it looks and how it feels.
- Okay. So this is the one
that's really portable.
This is the Intuos One.
This is a small Intuos.
So it's the one that you're
seeing like on my screen share
actually right now, it's a small one,
the one all the way on the right.
And so this is the
Bluetooth version of it.
And so literally, you know,
you just press the button
to turn it on and off.
And it's Bluetooth enabled.
And when I am using the pen here,
it works exactly like a huge mouse pad.
Okay. So you think of this as a mouse pad.
So like this top left corner corresponds
to the top left of my screen.
And this top, the bottom right
is like the bottom right of my screen.
So wherever I'm positioning my pen
is where I'm going to be
writing on the screen.
And so then I have a pen,
so it mimics exactly.
It's like a giant mouse pad,
and I'm able to write with the pen.
So that's this style of
tablet. I don't see my screen.
I have to like look up at my screen
to see where I'm writing.
So you might be thinking
this is so difficult.
Here's what I found. My
students all have one of these.
I have a classroom set of
these. It takes about a month.
So the first time they use it,
they're like, what is this thing?
How am I supposed to write with this?
It does take about a
month to get used to it,
to get used to like where
you're writing on the screen.
You're not dragging it like a mouse,
but you're actually just writing
on the part of the screen.
But once you get used
to it and you can't see,
but like there's these
little grids on it too.
So it's easy to like
align and write straight.
It's really helpful to have
those little grid lines.
I use it a lot. There's
also little buttons here.
If like you need to click
and so use it as like a
right click or something.
So you really can use
this to navigate anything
that you need.
And then yeah, I found you get
used to it in about a month.
And the writing on this is so wonderful.
Like this is used by artists.
So it's way more than I
need as a math teacher,
but it feels wonderful.
It feels like you're
writing on a piece of paper,
which is what I love.
And then the other one.
So what I use more often,
especially now, since I'm at home,
this is the Wacom One.
So it is like, okay,
let's see, much bigger.
It's 13 inches, okay?
This one, and this is a
pen display style One.
I don't have it plugged in right now
because I just didn't want to, like,
I was afraid with all these
people on that I was going,
my internet would lag or something
when I had too many screens plugged in,
and I have so many things plugged into
my computer right now.
So that's why I don't have it on,
but pretty much I keep this thing on,
plugged in all the time into my computer.
So again, you plug it in with
a USB into your computer.
So you plug it in with the USB.
You also do have to power
this one into a wall.
So that's just something to know.
But if you're making videos,
so you can see like kind
of on my screen here,
this would be the image,
it's mirroring your screen.
It's just like, if you're in a classroom
and you have a projector.
You know how it mirrors
exactly what's on your screen?
That's exactly how this works.
So it is like a second display,
and you're able to see
what you're writing on.
So it feels a lot more comfortable.
I mean, I definitely like my Wacom One,
what I use more often.
It's totally what I use for, all right.
So I use it for making my videos.
I also use it for grading student work.
So grading student work,
I actually use Kami.
Students just turn in a PDF.
I open it. I open up the PDF in Kami.
And I'm able to hand write all over it.
I'm also able to leave video comments
and able to leave voice comments
because we have a paid
subscription to Kami.
It's a huge tool.
If your school already has it
and you haven't explored it yet,
I really recommend checking it out.
If you have any questions,
I have like a video
library on Kami itself,
but I use it for that.
I use it for lesson planning
and I use it as like my daily like notes
because I can just mind
map whatever I want to do.
And I'm using my Wacom One for that
because I'm plugged in pretty
much all the time right now.
So I hope that helps.
- Oh, that's great.
And so, you know, the next
obvious follow up question
is like, Hey, this looks amazing,
but Max Sellers want to know,
does it work with my platform,
with my tools, in general,
are these compatible
with like Macs, PCs, Chromebooks?
Do you know about that?
- Yeah. Great question.
It is compatible with Macs and PCs.
It is not compatible with Chromebooks.
- Okay. Got it.
And then you were showing us
so many of these applications,
whether it was Jamboard or Kami.
I assume pretty much anything
where you're on a Mac and a PC
and you have a document that
you're interacting with.
You can use the tablet on it.
Is that right?
- Yeah. So again, any
of these Wacom devices.
Think of it as like how you're,
if your mouse currently
works with the program
and you're able to currently
like press the pen tool
and draw with a mouse
and you know the unpleasant experience
of trying to do that, then with the Wacom,
you just literally now have a pen
that you're writing, like you
are writing on the screen.
So think of it as your
mouse pad with a pen.
- Cool, cool. That's really helpful.
And then I think the
elephant in the room question
comes from Janette, who says,
Hey, I want one of these so
bad, but how do I afford it?
Have you heard about
teachers using Donors Choose
or other platforms to
make this more available
to their classroom?
- Yeah. I mean, definitely people have,
people have asked their schools too.
I know a lot of schools are
providing them this year.
So, again, if you wanted to ask
for the most affordable
option, the Wacom Intuos line
would be the one that
I would go for there.
And honestly, I would
ask for the Bluetooth one
because it's only like
$10 more for the Bluetooth
versus the wired one.
And it's something, this is my thing.
And I've talked to some
teachers about this
who want to ask their school about it.
This is not a device that
we are using just now
because of remote learning.
I've been using these devices
for years and years and years.
This is a device that's going to amp up
our classroom in all different ways.
There's so many ways we can use it.
We can use it in class.
We can use it before class to, you know,
make our flip classroom lead videos.
We can also use it post-class
to grade student work,
to make everything be in
one space for students.
There's also a lot of benefit
to having all of this saved
for students in their Google
Drive or whatever it may be
because don't forget if you
are making this digital work,
and you're saving it for
them in a digital way,
giving them that digital feedback.
Now it becomes searchable.
So that's something else
that's really powerful.
So again, I've talked a
little bit about Kami today,
but Kami is what I use.
And I grade the student work in that too.
And this has OCR, optical
character recognition.
And that means that
anything that's on here,
even like hand written
stuff becomes searchable,
super powerful there.
So that's what I would say is like,
this is not something that we're going to
just be using this year, not to mention.
So I showed you some of the
newer Wacom products right now,
but I'm being completely honest here.
I'm not just saying this because
you know Wacom's here with me,
but the class set of
tablets that I showed you,
like this class set here,
you can see that this
tablet looks different
than the one I showed you.
That's because this is an older version.
I got this class that in 2013.
It is still going strong.
I'm still using the same class
set of tablets since 2013.
Like what other technology are
you using seven years later?
And it works just as well
as it worked on day one.
And that's the, I think
the power of these things
is because like it's not
tied to an operating system
or anything like that.
You just plug it in to your computer
and you know, like worst case scenario.
Now the USB doesn't plug in
and I need a USBC adapter.
Like that's really the only difference,
but they have true staying power.
These things are built to last.
And so it's going to be
to me an investment for,
if you're making an
argument to your school
it's an investment for your school.
- Very cool.
Well, speaking of staying power,
I'm thinking so many
questions about battery life
because I think here in 2020,
our phones are dying, our iPods are dying.
We can't even get enough
chargers to plug everything in.
What's the battery life on these things?
- I don't know what the battery life is
on the Bluetooth one.
It lasts a really long time.
I mean, I really don't know.
I just plug it in occasionally.
It's not like it's not going
to run out during my class day.
It also doesn't stay on the whole time.
So I don't worry about that.
The Wacom One has to be plugged
into the wall all the time.
So there's that.
And then the class set that I have
is the one where they plug it in.
So I've never run into that before
because it doesn't, there's no battery.
So I don't know the exact specs
on how long the battery lasts.
- Very cool.
I see a lot of questions coming in
about like using this
for specific use cases.
I know you're a math
teacher, but you know,
if you were imagining a teacher,
especially in a special ed
special education environment,
who wants to use it to really
energize their students
during this very difficult time,
are there any tips you might recommend
to really use this to engage and harness
the creativity of their students?
- Yeah. Okay.
So, I guess the first thing
that I really believe in,
I really do believe in
the power of handwriting,
both for students and for us as teachers.
So for example, when I make
my flip classroom videos,
I'm always writing, as I'm talking.
I've seen some people,
they feel like their
videos look a little bit
more professional when
they write it all out
ahead of time because their
handwriting looks neater.
Like they're kind of scripting it.
They're able to write and then talk.
For me, students follow as I'm writing.
So I like to write and talk
because they're doing the same
and I want them to be taking notes
and they're able to kind of
see how I'm working through
the flow of that problem.
So I think there's huge power
in being able to write and talk.
So like, to me, a lot of times
I think that making a lesson
where I kind of have maybe,
even I'm just using the
Jamboard very simply
and I have a little bit of bullet points,
but then I'm writing as I'm talking.
I'm writing out some bullet points there.
I think it's more engaging
because students are seeing
something on the screen
versus just the flat text.
Do you know what I mean?
And even if you just draw
little images as you're going,
that can be really powerful too.
So I think it's auto
sketch that it's like,
is that what it's called?
I really liked that, auto
draw, that's what it's called.
Obviously it's saved to my thing
because like you can be
sketching as you're doing class.
I don't use it in my math class
but it recognizes what you're doing.
So like if I start drawing something,
it will recognize it,
so I can have terrible
drawing and be like, Oh yeah,
I was trying to draw a van
and so, you know, again,
so it can just be like the
power of having some visuals.
The students can see that
and maybe you could
allow them to, you know,
you could pass a tablet around
and allow them to sketch notes.
I think that's something else
that can be really powerful.
Having students summarize
what they're learning
through sketches and little annotations.
So again, you could
have them here drawing,
and then also they can use
just the regular draw tool here
and they can actually hand write there.
That wouldn't be auto recognized.
This magical one is the one
that's going to auto recognize
whatever you're writing.
So yeah, that could be just a
simple, really powerful tool.
- Yeah. I think that's
powerful for every student.
Like, especially in this
moment, we're all apart,
to bring more visuals, more
sort of eye catching moments
into our teaching is so powerful.
What about for younger students?
Again, I know that you teach
older students in your day job
but have you heard about
teachers using this successfully
with younger students,
especially if you're
giving them the tablets
and asking them to input
their own handwriting?
- Yeah, so I'm lucky I
work at a K-12 school,
so I get to see the younger
kids in our lower school grades.
All of our students are
actually using Seesaw.
So if your school is using Seesaw,
it's already built in there,
that they're able to draw on anything,
they're able to actually draw
and record at the same time.
So they can talk out their math thinking
or whatever thinking that they are doing.
And if you're able to pass out the tablet,
then they can really
practice the writing also,
which can be, you know, super powerful.
For our youngest students, they do,
I will say that they do very
well with just using a mouse.
And usually what they're
drawing is rather simple.
So maybe they're drawing some shapes
or you're trying to help them
like learn about counting.
And that's one of the most
difficult things right now.
I also have a niece that's six years old
and she's also using Seesaw.
And sometimes we get on the
video and we'd do it together.
And it's like, she's
trying to add the numbers
and she's doing really well with it,
but sometimes she just
needs those visuals.
So we're able to either draw them out.
Sometimes I tell my sister
to go get her some crackers
so that she can pull those up too.
And, but, you know, you
could even take a picture
of some of those, pull them
into Seesaw or whatever it is,
and then use the pen to
cross things out too.
I think that's the power,
like starting to verbalize
your thinking process.
So whether that's a student
or you as the teacher
who has a device and you're
able to really make it visual
to students what's going on.
And again, not just like
a PowerPoint presentation,
with some fancy animations,
I personally just find
those harder to follow.
I need to see the writing, the flow.
I also need to be doing the writing,
that to me, like I cannot,
I don't know about other math teachers.
I cannot like type a math solution.
Like when I'm doing my solutions,
I have to hand write it.
Maybe I'll type it up afterwards,
but I can't think like that.
- There's something about,
like, the sketching,
the doodling that actually
unlocks your brain
in a powerful way.
- Yeah. I also don't
think completely linearly.
I think that's it too.
Like with all these white boarding apps,
we can be writing in
different spaces on the screen
and it doesn't have to be so linear.
So we really can map information together
and help our students understand
how all this stuff webs together.
I think that's why I liked the AWW app
that I showed you too,
because you can have, like,
you can be writing here
and here and here and here
and then you can zoom out and
see that web all come together
and make those connections.
- Very cool, well, speaking
of making connections
you've connected so many
educators across the country
tonight, Stacey, to each other,
to awesome opportunities
in their classrooms.
So I have to thank you so much
on behalf of this audience.
That being said, any final words of wisdom
as folks get ready for the end of the year
and the start of a new one?
- Oh my gosh. Right.
First, I just want to say
thank you to everybody
who is on this call today
because I know how much
everybody's already doing right now.
And then taking the time out this evening
to just further grow as an educator.
I mean, this is why I love teachers.
When I first started teaching, I was like,
I know I'm in the right profession
as soon as I saw how
generous educators are
and just like that love of learning.
So I really appreciate you being here,
and everything that, you know,
you all are doing right now
in the classroom and
trying to make it all work.
If I can help in any way,
please do reach out again.
My information is here. Contact
information is on my blog.
Also, if you are on Twitter,
I'm very active on Twitter
and you can go ahead
and leave me a message.
And I will definitely respond back to you.
If you click on any of the
videos that I shared today, again
they're also in the PDF that
you can take home later.
If you watch some of those
videos that I have on YouTube,
and you have a question,
please just put it in
the comments on YouTube.
I definitely get to all
of my YouTube comments.
So that's sometimes the
easiest way, you know,
you were watching it
and you're like, well,
what do I do here?
Just let me know.
Because as I said, I just
wish that I could have come
to this today and said like,
these are the three apps that you need,
but that wouldn't be me being real.
Me being real is trying
to find what you're doing
at your school already
and offering a solution
that's going to work well
for you and your students,
even though I might have a favorite one,
that might not be what's best
for you and your setting.
So I hope that the variety of
tools kind of got you thinking
and then you will be able
to click on one of them,
zone in on that.
And as you do and as questions come up,
please do reach out and
I'll do my best to answer.
- Cool. Thank you so much, Stacey.
And thank you again to
everyone for joining tonight.
Just as a quick recap,
you will get an email
with a recording of the session,
as well as Stacey's PDF.
You'll get a link to that
generous discount offered by Wacom
and everyone who joined will automatically
be entered into a drawing for
one of five Wacom tablets.
And we'll notify those winners shortly.
In the meantime, thank you as Stacey said,
for all that you do.
We wish you a tremendous
conclusion to the year
and a great start to 2021.
And we can't wait to see
all the incredible things
you do next based on some
of these awesome tips.
Thank you so much, Stacey,
and good night, everyone.
- Thank you. Bye.